Speaker 1: Let's try instead with Tristan
in Kansas, Tristan in Kansas, you were on
the air.
Hey, can you hear me OK?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 3: OK.
Well, you kind of pull the Trump there, David,
because I'm actually in Kansas City, Missouri.
It's OK.
Speaker 1: I know it all gets truncated, so
all I could see was Kansas.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah.
So going to the situation in Ukraine.
Yes, there is.
Would you say there's a lot of quote unquote
western hysteria about this because I'm just
nonstop getting bombarded with news articles
and and videos about it and everything.
But you know, people of, you know, people
I talk to in Ukraine, they're saying it's
it's it's being sterilized or I don't know
the right word for it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I understand.
Well, I think there's a couple different things
going on.
First of all, a lot of the discussion around
Russia, Ukraine is related to Russia's role
in the world as one of the three major superpowers,
along with China and the U.S..
So a ton of the discussion.
You know, if if there is a population that's
about to be invaded, that population being
Ukrainians, one of the priority should be
what's going to happen to Ukrainians?
What do Ukrainians want?
What is it?
So, for example, Israel is helping to evacuate
Jews from Ukraine under the belief that if
Russia were to invade, it's probably not particularly
good for Jews.
That's about the people.
And what's that's being lost significantly
because the context is Putin versus Biden.
And will China take this as an opportunity
to be aggressive with Taiwan or whatever the
case may be?
It makes sense because these are big geopolitical
players.
But I do think that there's kind of a missing
element, which is the Ukrainian people.
That's a part of it.
The second part is, I do think that there's
significant politicization here.
Individuals looking to there are left and
right wingers that are increasingly aligning
with authoritarian regimes like Putin.
There's an opportunity to call Biden weak,
no matter what he does, and so there's a lot
of political opportunism as well.
Speaker 3: Of course, D, do you think there's
an actual possibility of World War three,
like a strong possibility in your eyes or
do you think that's hyperbolic, do you think?
I think
Speaker 1: that much.
I think that's hyperbolic and I know that
that there's, you know, Naito allies are increasingly
sort of preparing and putting troops at the
ready.
But I really don't think this is something
that even if Russia were to invade Ukraine,
I have I would bet against this going anywhere
else into any kind of World War scenario in
the immediate five years from now.
In a totally different situation, maybe.
But I don't think that that's hyperbolic.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it just it's really reminded
me a lot of, you know, I get really annoyed
when people compare Putin to Hitler because.
But I will say that it does mirror the beginnings
of World War Two a lot where Hitler would
annex his, you know, the territories in which
it's around.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
Here's the difference, though.
Here's the difference.
The world is completely different than it
was in the World War Two era, and as a result,
both of different geopolitics, technology
and biotechnology technology.
I mean, both weapons and surveillance technology.
I don't think that just because there's something
about it that is similar, it means the outcome
is going to be the same.
These could be famous last words, but I think
we have to consider the context in the world
in which this is happening.
Speaker 3: Yeah, exactly that was that was
my idea, but I just keep getting bombarded
with articles and fear mongering that couldn't
get any anxiety.
This helps a lot.
I have friends in Europe.
I talked to about this too, so it's good to
have different perspectives and not just be
stuck in like little bubbles.
But thank you so
Speaker 1: much, David.
My pleasure.
Thanks for the call.
Very, very important topic for sure.
Wow, folks.
The phone lines are packed today and we're
going to be speaking to a variety of different
people.
Why don't we go next to George in Dublin?
George, you were on the air.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 3: I can you can you hear me, I can.
OK, great.
So my question is actually about Ukraine as
well.
And it's a given that the U.S. and NATO have
violated their promise from from the 90s to
not expand eastwards.
Can we really?
And given that the U.S. has military bases
all over the world, yes.
Can we really say that Putin is the provocateur
in this situation?
Because seems to me that, you know, from a
structural perspective, you know, NATO's has
been provoking Russia for decades by expanding
eastwards.
Speaker 1: I don't buy it.
No, I don't buy it.
I mean, there's at a certain point we have
to be able to say, well, hold on a second.
We can do any kind of theorizing and analysis
we want.
We can we can have the conversation you're
having about Naito.
But you would you you would have to believe
that someone is sort of forcing Putin to mass
troops at the border.
And it just seems like a tough bridge for
me to cross.
No, I don't.
I don't.
I don't think so.
That's a little bit too far.
I'm fine with structural analysis, for sure.
But no, I don't.
That's not striking me as as something that
makes sense to me.
Speaker 3: I mean, I think I think I certainly
agree that Putin is is a dishonest actor.
OK.
But it just I don't I don't really think any
serious person could disagree with that.
But it just seems to me that, you know, from
the perspective of the Russian president,
you know what good is NATO's word or the U.S.
word when they said, we're not going to expand
eastwards?
Sure.
And then 14 eastern countries from countries
in the former Eastern Bloc get to join NATO,
you know?
Speaker 1: But you know, I think that the
counter still is.
If Putin is massing troops at the border with
Ukraine, he may be planning to invade Ukraine,
and it makes sense to game out that possibility.
You know, and I say this as someone who doesn't
want any conflict whatsoever.
Speaker 3: Yeah, sure, sure, definitely.
By the way, I'm sure you heard, but Justice
Breyer is about to retire, so yes, Biden may
have a chance to appoint someone the Supreme
Court.
Indeed.
So, yeah, thanks for taking things.
Thanks for taking my call.
All right.
Speaker 1: My pleasure.
Thank you so much for the call.
Very much appreciate that.